merci nuvignon
cette première demi-heure vous êtes
sénatrice centriste ne la Vendée
président de la délégation sénatoriale
au droit des femmes et à l'égalité des
chances entre les hommes et les femmes
on va longuement parler du rapport que
vous avez mis hier pardon sur la santé
des femmes au travail mais d'abord
évidemment l'actualité on l'a vu ce sont
ces tensions cette violence qui est
montée d'un cran cette nuit et qui
s'était tendu dans plusieurs villes du
pays après la mort d'un jeune homme de
17 ans tué à Nanterre est-ce que vous
êtes inquiète du climat qui est en train
de monter dans le pays d'abord vous dire
que c'est un terrible drame forcément la
mort d'un jeune de 17 ans que on pense
aux familles on pense à la famille on
pense aux proches mais que nous avons
besoin de sérénité pour que la justice
soit rendue que l'enquête soit menée et
moi j'appelle évidemment à ce que c'est
violence elle cesse il y a trop de
violence dans notre société la justice
elle doit passer la vérité elle doit
être donnée pour que ce
cette mort ne soit pas
inutile et pour cela et ben on a besoin
de sérénité et aujourd'hui elle n'est
pas là elle n'est pas là à partir et
surtout ce climat il est entretenu par
certains selon vous
il y a une autre actualité aujourd'hui
c'est le Conseil d'État qui de rendre sa
décision sur le port du hijab dans le
foot féminin la Fédération Française de
foot interdit les joueuses de jouets
voilées le rapporteur public dit que la
Fédération Française doit modifier son
règlement il y a donc de grandes chances
que les hijabs sont autorisés
il y a une séparation
voilà donc il doit la neutralité elle
doit exister je ne suis pas favorable au
port du jab dans les compétitions
sportives
et ben voilà laïcité elle doit être
appliquée la neutralité aussi et que
tous les ports religieux qui visent à
finalement
à favoriser leur radicalisme le
séparatisme le communautarisme ne
doivent tout ces signes où doivent
disparaître et ne doivent pas être
utilisés moi je préside la délégation le
rapporteur il dit c'est pas une
provocation le seul port d'huile jab
vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec ça je ne
suis pas d'accord je ne suis pas
d'accord et moi qui préside la
délégation aux droits des nous avons
travaillé de nombreuses reprises cette
année sur la situation des femmes en
Iran sur la situation des femmes en
Afghanistan et lorsque dans certains
pays les femmes se battent au risque de
leur vie pour retirer le voile c'est
quand même très dommage qu'en France où
nous avons des lois normalement qui nous
protègent et c'est la laïcité la
neutralité et bien qu'on soit encore à
débattre de ce sujet le sujet elles ne
sont pas agents du service public ce
sont des choses de foot elles peuvent
jouer voilà
nous allons organiser les Jeux
Olympiques il y a une charte olympique
ces signes religieux sont bannis dans
cette charte olympique alors allons
jusqu'au bout et respectons la Charte
olympique dans les compétitions de
football
on va parler de votre rapport le rappeur
le rapporteur par votre délégation la
délégation sénatoriale ou au droit des
femmes sur la santé des femmes au
travail un rapport très instructif on va
voir les principaux points avec notre
journaliste parlementaire mathiasarez
[Musique]
bonjour Oriane bonjour madame la
signatrice et Mathias vous allez donc
nous parler de ce rapport de la
délégation au droit des femmes voilà six
mois de travaux et un constat implacable
notre société souffre d'une
méconnaissance quasi totale des
conséquences du travail sur la santé des
femmes la présidente de la délégation
Annick billon ici présente et ses quatre
rapports Laurence Cohen Laurence
Rossignol Annick Jacquemet et
Marie-Pierre Richer ont consulté des
entreprises des professionnels de santé
ce sont des placés en Bretagne et
ailleurs pour mieux documenter et
aborder un sujet qui semble presque
tabou tant il est soupe tant il est
passé sous silence hors de ces travaux
la délégation attirer des
recommandations 23 pour être précis une
liste divisée en trois catégories
chaussées systématiquement les lunettes
du genre c'est à dire différencier sans
pour autant discriminer en fonction du
genre avoir une approche sexuée des
risques professionnels ou des conditions
de travail développer et adapter la
prévention à destination
[Musique]
jamais appliquer c'est un affront pour
la rapporteur Laurence Cohen il faut
aussi quand les lois ne sont pas
appliquées avoir en tout cas beaucoup
plus d'exigences et ne pas ne pas
s'empêcher d'avoir des notamment des
sanctions financières et des sanctions
financières qui sont dissurésives vous
partagez la vie de votre collègue du
Val-de-Marne ah bah forcément s'il y a
une noix elle doit être respectée mais
on sait très bien pour avoir participé à
une commission mixte paritaire hier sur
la proposition de loi sur la fonction
publique et l'égalité dans les postes à
responsabilité si on met des obligations
dans la loi si on ne met pas de sanction
c'est effet zéro
vous le montre du travail est-ce que
c'est un peu ce qu'on comprend en lisant
ce rapport est-ce que le monde du
travail il est trop pensé masculin vous
dites notamment que les postes de
travail les équipements sont pensés sur
les données d'un homme moyen ce qui a
été démontré avec les rapporteurs c'est
que il y a des difficultés et des
différences à reconnaître finalement que
la santé des femmes au travail elle doit
être embrassée c'est un sujet qui doit
être embrassé de manière différente on a
pas chaussé les lunettes de genre vous
l'avez dit mais parce que pourquoi parce
que beaucoup imagine qu'à partir du
moment où on va différencier on va
stigmatiser or l'objectif n'est pas là
et certains vous diraient les femmes
sont déjà stigmatisées sont déjà
traitées différemment dans le travail
donc l'idée c'est bien entendu de se
dire que les femmes elles elles méritent
l'égalité salariale l'égalité
professionnelle mais qu'il faut comme
comme ça a été dit prendre en compte des
éléments de santé c'est à dire que oui
les femmes ont leurs règles oui les
femmes peuvent avoir des gros oui les
femmes peuvent avoir des fausses couches
oui il peut y avoir la procréation
assistée médicalement et oui il y a
encore des sujets tabous comme la
ménopause comme les règles dans la
société et dans la rue du travail mais
vous dites même que avoir des données
spécifiques en fait c'est important pour
comprendre les maladies féminines pour
aider à les prévenir et vous n'avez pas
réussi par exemple à obtenir ces données
statistiques sur les données de santé
par exemple les arrêts maladie par sexe
ça vous les avez pas alors on ne les a
pas ce qui est dommage c'est que on sait
très bien que l'assurance maladie elle a
les arrêts de travail les accidents de
travail les maladies professionnelles ce
sont des données dont elles dispose la
seule chose c'est que elle ne les
communiquent pas et on ne travaille pas
dessus à partir du moment où vous avez
des statistiques si vous n'en faites
rien ça ne sert à rien donc aujourd'hui
ce que nous demandons c'est que ces
statistiques genrées elles soient
utilisées pour mieux prendre en compte
un exemple le cancer les cancers
féminins les femmes et bien elle elle
elles ont des cancers plus jeunes elles
ont des cancers plus jeunes ça veut dire
qu'elles sont plus en situation de
travail lorsqu'elles lorsqu'elles ont un
cancer et bien par exemple le retour à
l'emploi avec un cancer ce c'est quelque
chose qui n'est absolument pas abordé
dans l'entreprise le travail de nuit le
travail de nuit 26%
ça augmente de 26% le risque d'avoir un
cancer du sein lorsque vous avez un
travail de nuit ça a été prouvé il y a
une affaire qui est passée en justice
donc bien entendu il faut intégrer cela
dans la manière de gérer la santé des
femmes au travail est-ce qu'il y a des
maladies professionnelles qui touchent
les femmes et qui sont pas reconnues
comme telles alors il y a la différence
qui a été démontrée dans ce rapport
c'est que finalement les accidents de
travail des femmes sont bien sont très
différents des accidents de travail des
hommes les hommes ce sont des accident
visible ce sont des accidents qui
mettent parfois le pronostic vital en
jeu les
maladies professionnelles des femmes se
sont plutôt des troubles
musculo-squelettiques finalement des des
maladies invisibles et aussi du
psychologique et psychologique puisque
la question de la charge mentale un
charge mentale tout à fait d'ailleurs au
début du rapport on avait évité on avait
hésité à travailler sur ce sujet il y a
les risques psycho
il y a les violences sexuelles et
sexistes qu'elles soient vécues sur le
lieu du travail ou en dehors dans le
cercle privé donc tout ceci fait que ce
sont bien souvent des des mots
invisibles et c'est le titre du rapport
et alors on l'a vu Mathias évidemment
tous les points dont on vient de parler
sont des points d'accord il y a aussi un
des accords oui c'est le congé menstruel
alors déjà instauré par la commune de
Saint-Ouen en Seine-Saint-Denis cette
option qui vise à adapter la présence au
travail pour les femmes souffrant de
douleur liées aux règles séduites de
plus en plus certaines entreprises
l'appliquent déjà la Gironde le
département de la Gironde devrait
prochainement l'expérimenter et pour
autant et bien le congé menstruel n'a
pas convaincu tous les membres de la
commission au grande dame de Laurence
Rossignol elle aussi rapporteur n'est
pas tombé d'accord avec les collègues
sur le projet menstruel moi j'y suis
favorable elles sont plus inquiètes des
risques qui pourrait y avoir le congé
menstruel je précise c'est une
prescription médicale longue et la
possibilité pour les femmes de s'arrêter
quand elles souffrent sans perdre les
indemnésies journalières liées au délai
de carence quel risque pourraient faire
peser le congé menstruel madame je pense
ce serait caricaturé le rapport et les
conclusions du rapport de dire qu'il y a
un désaccord
nous avons
étudié le sujet de l'endométriose 10%
des femmes en souffrent un million et
demi deux millions et demi de femmes
donc c'est une c'est avec des douleurs
très importantes bien souvent en à cause
d'infertilité donc quelque chose qui
existe qui est démontré et qui et qui
mérite qu'on s'y qu'on le traite
différemment aujourd'hui c'est une des
propositions du rapport c'est à dire
d'inscrire dans la liste des maladies
invalidantes et donc l'endométriose est
prise en compte à ce stade le congé
menstruel est aujourd'hui porté comme un
totem je ne suis pas persuadé à ce stade
je n'ai que les femmes dans leur grande
majorité souhaitent finalement
bénéficier d'un congé menstruel bien
entendu il faut prendre en compte la
douleur des femmes les propositions qui
sont faites sur l'endométriose vise à
cela c'est-à-dire supprimer la journée
de carence notamment et donc toutes les
questions de la santé des femmes doivent
être prises en compte mais ne résumons
pas le fait que certaines décors et des
membres de la délégation et souhaité
travailler plus en amont ce sujet pour
vérifier parce que parfois on a des
bonnes idées mais ces bonnes idées il
faut déjà qu'elles soient voulue par les
femmes et voulu parler femmes qui
travaillent et nous n'en sommes
absolument pas pervers soit des
aujourd'hui pour certaines décors
on constate aussi dans ce rapport que la
grossesse fait encore il fait toujours
l'objet de stigmatisation alors qu'on
est en 2023
les inégalités économiques
professionnelles elle persiste elle
persiste et c'est pour ça que nous avons
voté la loi sur l'égalité
économique et professionnelle il y a peu
pour le secteur privé et c'est pour ça
que hier il y avait cette commission mix
paritaire sur une proposition de loi que
j'ai déposée avec avec Dominique
verrière et Martine filleul qui vise à
faire que dans les on a fait on a donné
des obligations au secteur privé on doit
aussi les donner dans le secteur public
et donc plus pour plus d'égalité pour
accéder à des responsabilités et donc
oui les inégalités elles persistent oui
la prise en compte de la santé des
femmes elle n'est pas aujourd'hui ce
qu'elle devrait être alors c'est valable
pour la grossesse c'est valable pour la
ménopause qui reste un sujet tabou
encore aujourd'hui ouais ça aussi c'est
assez surprenant à la lecture de votre
rapport pourquoi la ménopause s'arrête
aujourd'hui un sujet d'amour mais ça
reste un sujet tabou parce que la santé
des femmes
l'endométriose on en parle que depuis
une dizaine d'années à peu près donc il
est il est important qu'il y ait des
personnels soignants qui soient formés
au finalement aux pathologies
spécifiques des femmes mais actuellement
on a des travaux qui sont menés sur les
médicaments une commission
présidée par notre collègue Sonia de la
pauvreté là aussi dans le domaine de la
recherche dans le domaine des
médicaments on voit que la recherche
n'avance pas suffisamment par rapport à
la différenciation qu'on doit faire
entre les hommes et les femmes y compris
sur certaines maladies c'est le cas par
exemple de l'infarctus ou les symptômes
ne sont pas les mêmes et c'est vrai que
ces pensées pour les hommes on connaît
beaucoup moins les symptômes chez les
femmes et ça a des conséquences
évidemment dans la détection et dans la
mortalité en fait il y a des idées
reçues qui ont la vie dure et que on
imagine que les femmes ne font pas d'AVC
les femmes ne sont pas sujettes à cela
donc oui les femmes
c'est une cause importante de mortalité
chez les femmes et bien souvent les
critères ne sont les symptômes ne sont
pas pris en compte vous l'avez dit donc
oui il faut qu'on travaille sur la santé
des femmes c'est un travail qui doit
être mené par les professionnels de
santé et puis je vais vous citer un
exemple parce que cette histoire m'a
beaucoup touchée
j'ai été contacté récemment lorsqu'une
femme est enceinte
elle est suivie
très suivi médicalement et une fois
qu'elle accouche bien souvent le bébé
est extrêmement suivi mais la femme est
beaucoup moins suivie après
l'accouchement il doit communiquer
sur sur les risques aussi qui suivent le
post-partum et bien écoutez j'ai eu le
témoignage d'une jeune femme
sa sœur qui elle avait accouché elle a
été prise quelques jours après de gros
ma tête elle a consulté son médecin en
les reparti avec une boîte de doliprane
or dans l'après midi à la fin un AVC
post-partum elle est décédée c'était et
finalement cette prise en compte des
maladies spécifiques femmes on se
demande si voilà on a parlé des risques
psychosociaux tout à l'heure de la santé
mentale à voilà des pressions
post-partum elle a mal au crâne elle
sent pas bien elle doit être stressée
non les symptômes du femme doivent être
pris en compte comme les symptômes des
risques d'AVC comme pour un homme et
tout à l'heure on parlait de l'homme
moyen finalement on le dit dans le
rapport les équipements par exemple de
travail mais ils sont établis pour un
homme moyen sauf un homme moyen il a
peut-être pas des petites mains il a
peut-être des grands pieds et bien
souvent les équipements de protection de
protection ça veut dire que les femmes
lorsqu'elles travaillent elles sont
mises en danger ne sont pas adaptées que
ce soit des grands des chaussures des
vêtements de protection quelles sont vos
espoirs de voir aboutir certaines des
recommandations qui sont dans le rapport
et bien écoutez
il y a des dispositions qui qui méritent
être portées auprès du gouvernement il y
a des dispositions qui probablement
pourront se transformer en mesure en
amendement ou en proposition de loi
comme vous l'avez dit dans vos propos
faire il y a quatre rapporteurs il y a
des élections sénatoriales on va
peut-être comme la session s'arrête en
juillet on va laisser passer le
renouvellement sénatorial et on portera
bien entendu ce qui doit être porté
après il y a aussi des bonnes pratiques
on est allé en Bretagne vous l'avez dit
il y a des il y a des régions il y a des
collectivités il y a des des préfectures
de région qui qui ont travaillé et qui
sont en avance sur d'autres d'autres
régions et on doit on doit les prendre
un exemple aussi merci Mathias à tout à
l'heure à tout à l'heure on va parler
d'un autre sujet des hôpitaux publics de
la loir-riste et des risques de
fermeture de service et ce sera
évidemment à suivre dans le club en
Vendée on va aller justement Vendée on
va voir l'actualité dans votre
département on retrouve Caroline tronche
bonjour Caroline merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous vous êtes très actrice en chef
de TV Vendée on est ravi de vous
recevoir dans cette émission Caroline
Elizabeth borne est en Vendée
aujourd'hui la première ministre
attendue et première étape de sa visite
ce sera un élevage de volailles
exactement il vous imaginez bien qu'on
l'attend on l'attend un petit peu de
pièce ferme alors nous mais surtout les
agriculteurs et ça c'est un sujet que il
va parler évidemment à votre invité du
jour bonjour à Lyon la grippe aviaire
c'est une épisiotique qui frappe le
département depuis plusieurs années
maintenant et c'est un sujet en 2013 qui
touche quasiment tous les agriculteurs
du département mais également toute une
filière la Vendée c'est une terre
d'agriculture donc on a évidemment des
gens qui élèvent de la volaille mais
d'autres qui viennent ensuite la
chercher et puis la transformer la
Vendée c'est notre coq ce sont les
canards full art ce sont aussi de la
restauration au domicile bref énormément
de personnes qui travaillent autour de
la volaille notamment pas forcément
compte qu'on pouvait bien en revanche
quand la machine s'emballe un petit peu
c'est le cas actuellement il y a
beaucoup beaucoup donc de personnes qui
sont touchées la grippe aviaire pour
vous je vais pas vous faire un cours de
médecine parce que j'en suis bien
incapable en rejoint en revanche je vais
vous expliquer ces compétences à partir
du moment où vous avez une volaille un
poul
et dans un élevage pour des raisons
sanitaires on est obligé
d'abattre tout le lot c'est-à-dire tous
l'élevage donc vous avez des
agriculteurs qui sont en train d'élever
15000 poulets par exemple dans un hangar
qui a un matin réaliste qu'il y en a une
ou deux bêtes qui sont mortes après test
on se rend compte qu'elles sont dans ta
cause de l'agrippe aviaire et bien il
faut abattre tout le lot du jour au
lendemain on a un agriculteur qui se
retrouve comme ça avec toute sa
production son revenues donc qui part
alors il faut dire qui part à la
poubelle voilà derrière de jolis à
l'instant et ça veut dire des camions
qui vont pas venir chercher donc des
personnes qui sont mises au chômage
technique et derrière des
transformateurs qui ne pourront pas
préparer des foie gras préparer des
cordons bleus préparer des Wings et
compagnies voilà donc c'est
psychologiquement très très compliqué
sanitairement évidemment la situation
elle est sous contrôle en revanche ce
qu'on peut pas gérer elle fait
que cet impact sur le moral des
agriculteurs 2021 2022 on a eu j'ai
regardé un petit peu dans les chiffres
22 millions de relations ont été
abattues en France sur Sylvain deux
millions la moitié l'ont été en Vendée
on représente pas la moitié du
territoire français donc pour vous
donner un petit peu cet impact
psychologique rien qu'à travers ce
chiffre je pense que c'est c'est assez
clair et aujourd'hui on a donc des
agriculteurs qui ont tout simplement
abandonné abandonnés vous en avez
certains qui ont transformé leur hangar
d'élevage en complètement autre chose
les salles de travail des sols de
location d'autres ont changé de
production on a aussi cette vie qui est
rythmée par des arrêts préfectoraux
c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont interdits
vous avez aussi des questions pour
Annick billon qu'on ait le temps de les
poser et quel est le temps d'y répondre
alors justement la question c'est une
question d'agenda madame billon il y a
un mois à peu près vous avez posé une
question au gouvernement justement
concernant cette gripazer pour en savoir
un petit peu plus sur les modalités de
financement et calendaire alors est-ce
que 1h avant l'arrivée d'Elisabeth pomme
vous en savez un petit peu plus et vous
avez un petit message pour nos éleveurs
Vendéens bien écoutez d'abord bonjour à
vous vous savez décrit la situation de
manière précise en Vendée pour avoir été
au côté des éleveurs depuis que cette
grippe aviaire persiste en Vendée je
connais leur détresse leur désarroi
forcément
l'État et le gouvernement a mis en place
un certain nombre de mesures de
biosécurité notamment mais ce qui avait
été évoqué lorsque le ministre Marc féno
est venu c'était le plan de vaccination
avec la priorité donnée au canard donc
aujourd'hui il y a un plan de
vaccination qui est qui est déterminé je
ne pense pas que les modalités de
financement parce que si les chiffres
qui étaient annoncés étaient de 70
millions pour pour payer ce plan de
vaccination alors un il faut avoir les
vaccins de il faut vacciner de manière
urgente parce que c'est la solution
c'est la solution le ministre
travaillait également à ce que ces
vaccins ne bloquent pas les exportations
ce qui est aussi important parce que la
filière elle était riche et moi ce que
ce que je dirais c'est qui il faut tout
mettre en oeuvre il faut se mettre
collectivement en marche pour que la
vaccination fonctionne que la
vaccination ne bloque pas notre notre
capacité à être concurrentiel sur les
marchés et puis aussi garantir la
pérennité de la filière c'est ce que
j'ai entendu dans vos propos moi je suis
inquiète par rapport à la filière à
partir du moment où on détruit on tue
autant de volailles et bien on perd du
capital génétique on perd du
savoir-faire on perd des salariés aussi
qui se tournent vers d'autres métiers
donc nous devons d'être mobilisés je
regrette de ne pas être aux côtés de la
première ministre aujourd'hui je m'en
suis excusée auprès d'elle mais c'est
important qu'elles viennent nous avions
déjà eu Marco mettons tout en œuvre pour
que le vaccin soit réalisé que les bêtes
soient vaccinées et que la filière reste
finalement debout parce que vous l'avez
dit ce sont des emplois directs des
emplois indirects je pense aussi au
plumes nous avons une entreprise en
Vendée interprume qui qui ne travaille
qu'avec des plumes et de l'eau comment
elle va pouvoir
continuer son activité si nous n'avons
plus de volaille donc bien entendu je
reste mobilisé je n'ai pas tout à fait
répondu à votre question parce que je
n'ai pas la réponse et cette question
pourrait te poser à madame la Première
ministre aujourd'hui j'imagine
et son déplacement l'imagine Caroline ça
sera évidemment à suivre sur TV Vendée
merci beaucoup merci à vous d'avoir été
avec nous et merci d'avoir été notre
invité ce matin pour cette première
demi-heure dans 20 minutes dans le club
des territoires débat sur l'hôpital vous
l'avez dit c'est aussi évidemment un
sujet en Vendée manque de personnel
service fermé l'hôpital est-il prêt à
affronter l'été ce sera le débat du club
d'abord on accueille notre prochaine
invité Christian Cambon nous rejoint